from kickboxing to kicking everyone's
butt here are real martial artists who
appeared in the John Wick films the 2014
John MC film didn't Mark Daniel
bernhardt's first time sharing the
screen with Keanu Reeves he had
previously appeared as one of the
Sinister agents alongside views as Neo
and the Matrix Reloaded however John
Wick allowed the two to battle in a more
direct and sense encounter in the film
Bernhard plays one of vigo's Stooges
kirio he tries to suffocate John by
putting a bag over his head drawing a
tight and closely matched Clash for
survival Jon wins of course as Bernhard
revealed to Kung Fu Kingdom he trained
in kung fu and moved to kickboxing and
boxing at a later stage he also
practiced Taekwondo and trained under
Grandmaster he ill Cho when he did
Bloodsport too Bernhard has kicked his
way into numerous films and television
projects in the action genre he even had
a star involved in the short-lived
series Mortal Kombat Conquest speaking
about his John Wick experience with Kung
Fu Kingdom Bernhard credited Chads to
helski for how the fight scenes turned
out saying Chad is done every martial
art you can imagine is a master and
probably 10 Martial Arts there's nobody
else I know that's more gifted than him
not many people recognize Scott Adkins
as killer harken when images of the
character first surfaced for John Wick
chapter 4. yet the Kingpin s character
showed off something that most Adkins
fans have known for a while he is a
versatile and talented actor with
enviable martial arts skills whether he
is literally kicking it alongside action
Superstars like Jean-Claude Van Damme
and Sylvester Stallone and The
Expendables 2 fighting his way into
B-movie Excellence for the Boyka and
disputed or bringing the laughs to
Netflix's vampire comedy day shift
Atkins always delivers Wally has become
the Undisputed king of director video
action movies the British actor's
history with martial arts began when he
started taking Judo lessons at 10 years
old however a mugging incident in his
early teens inspired him to take his
training even more seriously prompting
his studies of Taekwondo and kickboxing
eventually he trained himself up to
instruct the level in kickboxing as
Adkins revealed to the rap He has known
shots to hellski for a while and that's
to be a part of the John Wick films I've
been bugging him since John Wick won
eventually the director brought Adkins
into the fold but informed him his role
wouldn't be as straightforward as he
imagined Adkins told the outlet saleski
said you're gonna be in a fat suit
playing this German head of the German
table I actually relished The Challenge
and the opportunity to create such an
amazingly evil yet Jolly character does
Donnie Yen even need an introduction at
this point he's one of the most
celebrated Hong Kong action stars of all
time his films have changed the
landscape of action Cinema and pushed
the boundaries of what's possible with
each release rightfully so John Wick
chapter 4 includes a bona fide Legend
and the role of Kane an acquaintance of
John and the lethal blind assassin in
terms of martial arts ability yen is a
real deal in an interview with Men's
Journal he revealed his martial arts
training started at a young age saying
my mother was a martial arts master and
she used to run a wushu score so I
started my training with her but there
was a quick Fascination for what the
body could turn into as well as with the
physical aspect of martial arts I was
innately a curious person and I found
myself hungry for knowledge on how to
get stronger yet explained how his
desire to improve took him down a path
of Discovery where he also been involved
in boxing classes and took a
bodybuilding all these elements combined
helped him to build the discipline
needed for martial arts and acting when
he was cast as the iconic ape man Yen
also trained with Wing Chun Masters
develop finger skills even further
without a shadow of a doubts marked to
Costco's as one of the most underrated
actors in the business since the early
90s he has appeared in smaller budget
films such as Only the Strong and
Brotherhood of the wharf however he only
received his flowers when he was cast as
a main antagonist zero in John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum I am happy to say
that on John Wick no injuries thanks to
his electric performance and phenomenal
moves the world finally saw it at
Costco's has the action chops to rival
the van dams and cigars of the world the
cascos has a serious martial arts
pedigree in real life as well his father
is sifu out to cascos the founder of one
hop kindo Kung Fu while his stepmother
Malia to Costco's Bernal is one of the
most celebrated and dominant martial
arts fighters in the U.S in an interview
with inside Kung Fu to Costco's revealed
how he had maintained his training in
one Hopkin doe while also learning Muay
Thai he also discussed why he never
stopped training even when he wasn't
doing many action projects at the time
he sold the outlet that come from a
traditional martial arts family and it's
my hope I never stop training and I
never lose that traditional aspect of it
meaning that salutation before and after
class the respect the discipline the
honor I love that Chilean actor Marcos
of War might not be an instantly
recognizable name to the general
American audience but for action
connoisseurs his presence in a film is a
sure indication that it will
metaphorically and literally kick hard
in John Wick chapter 4 the roar plays
Chidi the ruthless high table member who
tests the Ayah of everyone as he
attempts to put down another dog in this
franchise fortunately no one is about to
let that slide around here anymore and
he gets his Just Desserts the roar
became interested in martial arts after
watching the likes of Jackie Chan drawn
Claude Van Damme and Bruce Lee inspired
by these on-screen Superstars so raw
began his training at a young age and
was well established in Taekwondo and
kickboxing by the time he was an adult
from there his past took him into
modeling before he found his footing in
acting speaking to film journalist Rohan
Patel it's a role revealed how much work
he puts into her preparation for his
movies he explained he treats them as if
they are his Olympic Games and he needs
to arrive on set ready to compete at the
highest level
that's a big bout of John Wick chapter 3
Parabellum zero has a few disciples who
door with a John in the film two
official Nobi assassins face off against
Jon and arguably the film's centerpiece
fight in the glass office one of the
Assassins is portrayed by actor and
martial artist yayan ruhyan Indonesian
action Cinema fans they're all about
ruhiyan from his appearances in Gareth
Evans The Raid films he is very fast and
able to keep up with other Sublime
martial artists such as Joe taslim and
Iko ueis ruhiyan is a practitioner of
penchuk silat and became an in-demand
instructor even teaching the Indonesian
police force at one point in his career
however martial arts isn't simply a
hobby for him as the large became a
major part of his whole being he told
the Jakarta post there is something that
you call we Raga physical aspects birasa
artistic aspects and we Rama Rhythm
aspects in Salat as a large practitioner
must be able to master these aspects and
they will eventually be beneficial in
their lives Evo Yuki Sonata has been in
the film industry for decades Molly
transitioned to Hollywood in the early
2000s it feels like he only recently
started receiving the praise he deserves
part of playing Scorpion in 2021's
Mortal Combat and appearing in bullet
train and army of the Dead Sonata was
Caster shimazu Koji in John Wick chapter
4. Sonata is also an accomplished
martial artist who decided early on in
his life that he would combine his love
of martial arts with acting he explained
to Kung Fu magazine that he enjoyed both
Bruce Lee and Steve McQueen so he found
a way to merge all his passions into one
he trained in shorinji Kempo and kyoku
shinkai karate before he joins Japanese
legendary actor Sunny Chivas dunscore
tonata credited Chiba as his mentor
saying when I was 13 and training with
sunny he told me that acting and actors
have a long life like a marathon so the
most important things to continue acting
and by the time I reached 30 that will
be the time when I get a real first big
chance to do something the biggest
highlight of the John Wick films is
discovering how Innovative junk can be
when he finds himself in trouble not
only can he adapt his fighting style but
he can also switch up his strategy when
he encounters New and challenging
opponents in John Wick chapter 2 he
meets a Sumo assassin who isn't going
down easy even after a hail of bullets
and Swift kicks to the groin he appears
to be an immovable object until the head
shot from Jon's pistol does the trick
the Sumo assassin is portrayed by
Yamamoto Yama ryuta who is a former
Japanese sumo wrestling champion he was
considered one of the heaviest sumo
wrestlers of all time before
transitioning into acting director Chad
stachelski revealed to flickering myth
that before John Wick chapter 2 he saw a
sumo fight and decided he wanted to
include a sumo wrestler in the movie
then he met ryuta and was immediately
impressed by his sheer size
I know Kung Fu Gianna Reeves owes a lot
to Tiger who Chan initially the two met
on the set of the Matrix where Chen
acted as Reeves martial arts teacher and
taught in the moves he needed to portray
Neo from there a friendship develops
between the two of them with Reeves
eventually directing the 2013 movie Man
of Tai Chi and casting Chen in a pivotal
role Shannon Reeves received another
chance to combine their powers in John
Wick chapter 3 Parabellum where Chen
portrayed a Triad assassin before
leaving into Hollywood Chen achieved
success as a martial artist he had
trained in wushu since a tender age of
eight and participated in several
competitions before impressing in karate
as well his life changed though when he
met fabled Hong Kong choreographer Yuen
Wu ping and it kick-started his journey
into the world of Cinema
John Wick started as a Revenge film but
has evolved into a massive Universe with
intriguing lore and dynamic characters
in John Wick chapter 3 Parabellum the
Elder is introduced as a mysterious
figure who works with the high table
portraying the character as french actor
Syed tag Maui while the actor is now
known for his role in John Wick and his
appearance in Wonder Woman he was a
boxer before he decided to hang up his
gloves for the lights camera and action
he was quite accomplished as well
ranking second in his weight class in
France his role as the Elder also came
at the right time for him as he had
suffered something of a career setback
in the recent past Target Maui revealed
he had been set to portray the bond
villain when Danny Boyle was attached to
the project that became no time to die
however after the director famously left
a production the filmmakers went in a
different direction one without tag Maui